Corsets dominated the undergarments of wealthier
women in the Western world for centuries,
until WWI.
So how did the war help popularize the bra?
In a word, or two words in this case: metal
shortage.
The making of corsets required quite a bit
of metal.
Thus, in 1917, the U.S. War Industries Board
asked American women to help their “men
win the war” by not wearing or buying corsets.
This may seem like it would only make a small
difference; but, in fact, during the war it
is estimated that they freed up around 28,000
tons of steel by this change.
(Similar reasoning later led to the banning
of pre-sliced bread in the U.S. during WWII,
with much less success.)
Besides conserving resources, other aspects
of the war also contributed to the demise
of the corset and the rise of the bra.
For instance, during the war, American women
found themselves working in factories, places
where it simply wasn’t possible to function
properly wearing an ultra-tight, ultra-restrictive
corset.
Still needing some support in these active
jobs, the bra became the most used alternative.
By the end of the war, fashion-conscious women
in North America and Europe were now mostly
wearing brassieres and soon mass-production
of bras ramped up, despite their no longer
being metal shortages nor were as many women
still working factories and the like.
Women in Asia, Africa, and Latin America followed
the trend.
The reason the switch was more or less made
permanent was that corsets were designed to
accentuate the curvy Victorian ideal of beauty
by cinching the waist and boosting the breasts.
In the process, this made it very difficult
to breathe and squeezed women’s waists so
much that it could even displace organs and
cause certain internal problems, along with
symptoms such as fainting, gynecological issues,
flushing, and nausea, among others.
With corsets out, women could move and breathe
again.
So who invented the first bra?
Wearing a specialized garment to support a
woman’s breasts dates as far back as at
least the 14th century BC in Greece where
women wore a band of wool or linen that was
wrapped across the breasts and tied or pinned
in the back.
Depictions of these first bras can be seen
in wall drawing in Crete, worn by female athletes
during athletic events.
The women in this civilization also seem to
have often worn bra-like clothing items that
were actually designed to expose the breasts,
while also pushing them up and making them
more prominent.
As to the modern bra, it isn’t clear who
was the first to invent it as numerous patents
in various nations were filed in the mid-19th
to early 20th centuries concerning bras.
Along with the official patent records, an
early 19th century push-up bra was recently
discovered in the London Science Museum storage
rooms; so even before they were being patented,
at least some intrepid women seem to have
been wearing something like a modern bra design.
The apparent “first” modern bra design
patented in the U.S. was made by Caresse Crosby,
born Mary Phelps Jacob, who invented her design
in 1910.
She got the idea for her bra when she was
just 19 years old and heading to a ball.
Her dress for the evening was a sheer gown.
Owing to her large breast size, the dress
and a corset didn’t work- the whale bone
in the corset stuck out of her dress at the
top.
She then, with the help of her maid, took
two handkerchiefs and some ribbon and sewed
them together to make something like a modern
day bra, so she would still have support but
not need to wear the corset.
After her bra being the talk of the party,
with several women requesting she make bras
for them, she decided to make a business out
of it and patented her “backless brassiere”,
with the patent being approved on November
3, 1914.
She initially didn’t have much luck selling
her bra and decided to close down the business,
selling the patent rights to Warners Brothers
Corset Company of Connecticut.
From the sale she profited $1,500, which is
approximately $30,000 today.
Not bad, until you consider that Warners Brothers
Co. managed to do quite a bit better with
the patent, ultimately earning an estimated
$15 million, $200-$300 million today, from
it in the following three decades.
Various advancements were made on these early
bras, reflecting the shifting fashion trends.
In the 1920s, the flat chested, flapper look
was queen, and bra styles reflected this.
Soon a full chested look, not unlike what
was produced by corsets, became popular again.
In 1947, Frederick Mellinger, founder of Frederick’s
of Hollywood, introduced his design for the
padded bra; a year later, his design for the
modern push up bra came out which was called
“Rising Star”.
Before 1950, Mellinger would also introduce
us to the front hook bra and more colorful
brassieres.
In 1977, Lisa Lindahl and her childhood friend,
Polly Smith, fashioned the modern day sports
bra out of two jock straps (seriously).
They teamed up with clothing designer Hinda
Miller and soon the “Jogbra” was available
to the general public.
That same year Victoria’s Secret was founded
by Stanford MBA, Roy Raymond.
How we size bras wasn’t invented until the
late 1920s or 1930s, with some contention
over who actually invented the modern sizing
system.
Some historians credit William Rosenthal and
his wife Ida.
Others claim it was S.H.
Camp and Company who introduced the A, B,
C, D letter sizing, with documented evidence
of Camp and Co.’s claim appearing in early
1930s ad campaigns showing such sizing.
Whoever was really first, the brassiere sizing
system, at least as far as the terminology
went, soon caught on with other bra manufactures.
Before this, bras tended to come in a mostly
one size fits all variety, using stretchable
material in the cup to accommodate women of
varying sizes.
The sizing method that was come up with, which
by the way is not standard from nation to
nation, and can even vary somewhat from manufacturer
to manufacturer, consists of two measurements
– a linear measurement measuring underneath
the breasts and around the ribcage, and then
a second measurement, measuring the bra cup
size itself, which is measured in volume.
In this system, an A cup generally can hold
around 8 fluid ounces; a B cup around 13 fluid
ounces; a C cup around 21 fluid ounces; and
a D cup around 27 fluid ounces.
Not surprisingly, considering the slight variance
in sizing from bra maker to bra maker and
country to country, as well as the fact that
weight fluctuation in a woman, even as little
as 5-10 pounds, effect bra size, the general
consensus is that the vast majority of women
out there wear the incorrect bra size.
Because of this, it’s often recommended
that every single time you go bra shopping,
you get re-measured and have a sizing expert
make sure a given bra actually is fitting
you correctly.
The world’s biggest breast augmentation
is 38KKK.
Those mammoth mammaries are sported by Sheyla
Hershey, originally from Brazil, taking her
10 different surgeries to get up to that size.
Sheyla’s goal is to some day get her boobs
up to 38MMM.
While her reasoning behind the surgeries may
be essentially vanity (wanting to hold and
keep the world record), Sheyla claims her
38KKK breasts once saved her life during a
car accident where she wasn’t wearing her
seatbelt.
Her implants functioned something like an
air bag, keeping her from smashing her head
on the dash or windshield.
Lucky for her, considering the volume of fluids
in them, during the accident, her implants
did no burst.